j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public et il tient d'une question
comment enseigner l'histoire un sondage
récent montre d'inquiétante lacune des
16 24 ans sur des dates des notions
essentielles par exemple 4/1 n'ont
jamais entendu parler de la rafle du
veldive 1/ 5 doute même de l'existence
de la Choa avant d' débattre notre
reportage lors d'une cérémonie justement
de commémoration des victimes de
l'Holocauste avec Yan
eé si bougies allumé en hommage au 6
millions victime de la Choa chaque 27
janvier l'Europe perpétue la mémoire de
l'extermination des Juifs ici au
Mémorial à Paris les derniers survivants
tiennent à transmettre leur histoire
malheureusement je ne sais pas si mon
témoignage continuera mais il y a pas
une semaine où je ne témoigne pas devant
les établissements scolaires j'ai fait
plus de 15 voyages à auswitz pour
accompagner des élèves des étudiants à
la cérémonie quatre lycées sont
représentés par plusieurs élèves
volontaires c'est nous la nouvelle
génération donc c'est un peu notre rôle
bah de de continuer à parler des
événements et perpétrer la mémoire cet
enseignement doit nous être donné
inlassablement dans les écoles dans les
mémoriaux des paroles fortes prononcées
devant des élus oui c'est à la fois
émouvant et important moi ce que je
souhaite c'est que ce soit faisable et
possible dans tous les lycées de France
pas seulement dans certains car depuis
les assassinats de Samuel Patier
Dominique Bernard des professeurs
d'histoire en particulier redoutent
d'aborder certains thèmes pour cette
enseignante l'étude de la matière est
plus nécessaire que jamais s'il y a des
oppositions frontales on peut les
entendre et c'est là par contre c'est la
manière dont on va les prendre en charge
qui est importante c'està-dire il s'agit
pas de se lamenter il s'agit de prendre
ce dénis à bras le corps et là de se
lancer dans des projets et de faire
s'incarner les choses des statistiques 6
millions de juives d'Europe deviennent
Rachel
brutalement ça parle à tous les lycéens
présents deviennent des ambassadeurs de
la mémoire chargés à leur tour de
transmettre le souvenir de
l'Holocauste comment enseigner
l'histoire voilà la question centrale de
notre débat j'accueille Benjamin stor
bienvenue vous êtes historien hauteur du
rapport public les questions mémorielles
portant sur la colonisation à la guerre
d'Algérie vous aviez remis il y a 3 ans
au président de la République et puis
vous publiez ce livre l'arrivée de
Constantine à Paris c'est aux éditions
Talandier Paco bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes sénateur les républicains à
l'air de loise professeur agrégé
d'histoire géographie Christine guimonet
bonsoir bons bienvenue à vous aussi
professeur d'histoire géographie au
lycée Camille pissarois Pontoise et
secrétaire général de l'Association des
professeurs d'histoire Go et Mathieu
croissandau bonsoir bonsoir Mathieu
éditorialiste politique bon on avait
notre reportage sur cette commémoration
de des victimes de de de l'Holocauste je
commence avec ce thème Benjamin Stora
est-ce que cette cette transmission on
est plus dans la transmission de la
mémoire que dans l'enseignement de
l'histoire d'ailleurs on va pas c'est
pas exactement la même chose évidemment
est-ce qu'elle est condamné à se diluer
à s'estomper au fil des ans vous savez
le travail de l'historien c'est un peu
comme le myth de cisif il faut sans
arrêt sans arrêt recommencer il faut pas
croire qu'une histoire officielle et
définitive est dite et qu'à partir de là
tout doit découler pas du tout c'est
précisément pour ça qu'existent les
historiens c'est de remettre sans arrêt
sur le entier et euh de réexpliquer sans
cesse aux nouvelles générations donc de
s'assurer aux bonnes transmission
générationnell c'est c'est là la
question l'éducation c'est la question
de la transmission mais de dire
attention on connaît moins on sait plus
c'est normal je veux dire que les
sociétés ne vivent pas en état perpétuel
de souvenir traumatique ben les sociétés
elles avancent elles se projettent vers
le futur elles vivent pas sans arrêt
dans le souvenir des catastrophes des
deuils des guerres des émeutes elles
vivent au présent et donc dans ce
présent la tâche des historiens citoyens
c'est sans arrêt de leur dire attention
si on veut avancer et se projeter vers
l'avenir retenir les leçons du passé
est-ce que Olivier Pacot plus le le le
traumatisme est lointin s'éloigne dans
le temps plus ça devient difficile de le
de le partager
finalement c'est possible surtout dans
notre société où les nouvelles
technologies ont à mon
avis de façon ont énorme modifié la
façon d'enseigner l'histoire je
m'explique
oui nos élèves sont
aujourd'hui soumis à une avalanche
d'image parfois de
contevérité et le professeur d'histoire
c'est une sorte de d'allumeur de
réverbère il met en lumière il
explique à à l'ône du passé le présent
or aujourd'hui hi les
enfants sont tellement submergés
d'images que ils ne rêvent plus au récit
historique quand j'étais gamin il y a
pas si longtemps que ça au fond de la
classe j'avais des images d'épinales ça
me faisait rêver aujourd'hui les gamins
ne rêvent plus entre guillemets les
images les écrans les réseaux sociaux
rêvent pour eux donc le travail du
professeur a changé il est encore plus
important j'ai l'impression qu'hier et
il faut vraiment partir de cette
problématique de de la multiplicité
d'images qui complexifie tout est-ce que
vous êtes sur sur cette ligne Christine
guimonis est-ce que ça vous semble plus
compliqué notamment et puis après il y a
plein d'autres thèmes évidemment à
dérouler mais notamment à cause de cette
profusion d'image d'ailleurs parfois de
manipulation ou de fausses informations
diffusées sur les sur les réseaux
sociaux alors plus compliqué oui et non
parce que en travaillant au fil des
années avec les
élèves on se rend compte que ils ont goû
pour l'histoire oui euh qu'il faut
pouvoir susciter et développer euh il
s'intéresse toujours à ce qui se passe
nous sommes les premiers qui viennent
interroger lorsqu'il se passe quelque
chose dans le monde madame expliquez-moi
bon euh parf notre rôle c'est de le
raccrocher parfois à leur histoire à euh
oui ça ça aussi parce qu'en fait il ne
faut pas qu'ils ai l'impression que
l'histoire ce serait enfin l'histoire
avec un grand H même si l'expression est
pas forcément impertinente ce serait
comme une ste de tapis roulant qui
avancerait h et eux seraient à côté
d'accord et la la meilleure manière de
de les connecter en fait à cette
histoire c'est de travailler justement
avec une sorte de frise qui présente le
programme de l'année quels sont les
événements majeurs et on va placer leur
leur génération familial qu'est-ce que
moi en tant qu'élève j'ai j'ai pu
connaître qu'est-ce que la génération de
mes parents a pu connaître qu'est-ce
qu'on a pu leur raconter de ce qu'ils
n'ont pas vécu et comme ça on remonte et
ça leur permet aussi de de tisser un
petit peu ce ce
euh ce lien et pour comprendre que le
cours d'histoire ça les concerne aussi
que même si dans le programme ils ont
l'impression parfois que ça n'est pas
leur propre histoire mais c'est
l'histoire apprise par tout le monde il
y a toujours des des passerelles à faire
pour pour les connecter et pour les pour
les agrippper et pour revenir à ce que
disait monsieur sénateur Paco le la
prolifération enfin d'information ça a
peut-être aussi un effet négatif dans le
sens où ça peut les empêcher de se poser
et pour faire de l'histoire il faut
pouvoir se décentrer il faut pouvoir se
poser parce qu'on a besoin de temps nous
on est dans le temps pédagogique c'est
pas le temps médiatique et c'est pas le
temps politique et ça c'est la guerre de
la tenention et là c'est un autre débat
sur le modèle économique des réseaux
sociaux qui fonctionne sur laattention
qu'on leur qu'on leur porte évidemment
alors je voudrais qu'on reste quand même
sur le la question de alors là vraiment
l'enseignement de de la déportation des
Juifs l'enseignement de la choix et je
vous propose un témoignage parce que il
y a aussi les rescapés qui jouent leur
rôle dans cette transmission de mémoire
et dans cet enseignement d'une certaine
façon un témoignage celui de Lili Lenel
elle a été déportée à l'âge de 11 ans et
là elle est vous allez voir elle est
dans sa voiture elle sera à la coupole
musée dédié à la Seconde Guerre mondiale
dans le Pas de Calais elle va témoigner
devant une centaine de collégiens on
l'écoute un élève un petit élève mignon
un jour m'a dit en souriant et jusqu'à
quel âge madame vous avez l'intention de
témoigner de la sorte en souriant je lui
ai répondu oh tu au moins jusque 100 ans
après on verra donc vous voyez je dois
tenir encore 10 ans quand nous ne serons
plus là c'est à vous de d'avoir à
transmettre ce que vous savez vous êtes
mes petits messagers et ça ils y
tiennent à ce mot-là mes petits
messagers dans la lettrre il leur
appelle madame soyez assurés nous serons
vos messagers et nous n'oublierons
jamais Benjamin St ces témoignages ben
évidemment dans quelques années on aura
plus de de rescapé de la choix vivant ou
vivante comment on va les les les mettre
en perspective comment on peut les
utiliser est-ce que il faut les les
diffuser tel que finalement se dire
tiens ils ne sont plus là mais on vous
diffuse un résumé de de leur dernier
passage comment vous vous nous
conseillez de les utiliser il y a
plusieurs façons de de transmettre
l'histoire il y a bien sûr le récit
historique écrit par les historiens à
partir des archives à partir des sources
à partir de la
confrontation du témoignage c'est un peu
un travail journalistique d'ailleurs
quelque part il y a aussi le travail sur
la fiction il y a deux grands films qui
sont sortis sur les écrans allemand la
conférence et le film de Jonathan Glazer
sur la vie d'un commandant SS enfin du
commandant principal ssuswitz Hus à
Auschwitz HM qui son j'ai V ce weekend
qui est enfin j'ai vu sont des films
absolument extraordinaires et qui à
travers le travail de la fiction nous
permet de rentrer dans la cohérence de
l'histoire dans la cohérence du récit
historique la zone d'intérêt je cherchis
le titre parce que vous l'avez pas donné
zone d'intérêt absolument tout à fait
donc je pense que les historiens doivent
se confronter à la question des images
se confronter à la question du récit
historique ne pas les délaisser ne pas
se réfugier dans la sphère académique
comme séparé du réel faut au contraire y
aller donc plus que jamais nous avons
besoin d'histoire et des historiens pour
aller travailler sur des récites fiction
et d'ailleurs que ce soit sur la Seconde
Guerre mondiale la guerre d'Algérie ou
autre on voit très bien que des certains
films ou certains romans même pas
simplement des des films joue un rôle
d'éducation je pensais par exemple le
livre d'Alice zénitaire l'art de perdre
sur la guerre d'Algérie qui est un très
très beau roman et qui nous a fait
pénétrer dans un univers qui peut être
touché directement par toute la nouvelle
génération donc il y a plusieurs façons
de transmettre l'histoire maintenant
attention la mémoire c'est pas
l'histoire non non je je l'ai dit au
début je je mélange un peu les deux j'
suis vous avez raison parce que c'est
vrai que la frontière était tenue
fragile les historiens sont pas des
mémorialistes ils sont pas non plus
prisonniers de la tyrannie des mémoires
il faut aussi qu'il rédigent et qu'ils
élaborent et qu'il prennent des
distances par rapport à la mémoire h
parce que sinon on risque à la fois
disons d'être prisonnier des mémoires et
d'être mémo des mémoires communautarisé
et parce que chacun va s'enfermer dans
sa propre mémoire au risque de ne pas
écouter la mémoire des autres alors on a
titré ce débat l'histoire sous pression
au pluriel pression au pluriel je reste
sur l'enseignement de la choix Olivier
Pacco est-ce que c'est de plus en plus
difficile à enseigner dans certaines
classes je fais pas évidemment de
généralisation écoutez visiblement il y
a eu des des cas dans certains endroits
où o certains élèves refusent
euh la choix tel qu'elle est enseignée h
personnellement j'ai jamais subi ce
genre de problématique mais on peut pas
nier que ça puisse exister qu'il ait d'
négationisme chez certains élèves donc
effectivement il faut déconstruire de
fausses mémoires dans ces cas-là et le
professeur a un rôle pédagogique
essentiel il y a beaucoup d'outils on a
évoqué effectivement avec Benjamin Stora
la fiction le film qui peut être
effectivement une porte d'entrée
remarquable la littérature à un certain
niveau Primo Levi c'est c'est c'est pour
des élèves de lycée merveilleux la bande
dessinée peut aussi parfois être un
outil tout à fait formidable mais on a
des images d'archives aussi qu'on peut
utiliser qu' faut savoir utiliser de
façon évidemment très délicate mais
c'est là que chaque professeur dans le
choix de ces images qui peut varier en
fonction de la classe qu'il a en face de
lui en fonction des élèves à un rôle clé
ouais Christine vous êtes secrétaire
général de l'Association des professeurs
d'histoire géographie est-ce que vous
avez depuis je sais pas une dizaine
d'années plus de remonté de vos
collègues qui nous disent parler de la
choix ça devient compliqué notamment
disons les choses avec certains élèves
de confession musulmanes pas
particulièrement
euh en fait c'est un c'est une
problématique qu'il ne faut ni minimiser
ni généraliser on peut tous à un moment
donné de notre parcours professionnel
être confronté à de la contestation du
refus euh pour l'enseignement de la
choix dans mes propres classes jamais
j'ai par contre eu plusieurs élèves qui
ont un problème avec le génocide
arménien euh un problème une année pour
emmener une classe à Auschwitz les
élèves c'é les élèves volontaires ils
étaient euh vraiment très très engagés
il y a un père d'élèves qui a refusé que
sa fille participe au voyage parce que
l'argument c'était bon les deux guerres
mondiales enfin les deux guerres
mondiales ralbol
donc sa fille était très déçue mais on
allait pas entrer en conflit avec le
père pour pour qu'après ce soit
difficile à la maison très honnêtement
le génocide arménien çavit être des
élèves d'origine turque oui quand il a
un conflit il faut il faut le saisir à
bras le corps c'est-à-dire que le
professeur il est là pour expliquer pour
décrypter c'est pour ça que le temps le
temps pédagogique c'est très imp
important il faut savoir toujours enfin
du moins essayer de savoir toujours
qu'est-ce qui pousse l'élève à affirmer
ceci ou cela ou à contester est-ce que
c'est pour faire de la provocation ou
bien est-ce qu'il y a de la
méconnaissance de vocabulaire est-ce que
il y a aussi les contestations
adolescentes bon il y a plein de
problématiques spécifiques donc il faut
creuser et euh essayer de comprendre
pourquoi ça veut pas dire qu'on excuse
du tout mais si si vraiment après il y a
des propos négationnistes donc là il y a
la la sanction qui va qui va arriver et
si on dit allez ça on en parle pas en
fait on va le laisser dans ses
préjugés on pas
avancétorien il est là pour pour
décrypter pour analyser pour croiser les
sources et en classe c'est ce qu'on fait
en utilisant tous les types de support
en fonction de ce qu'on veut faire avec
les élèves et de manière adaptée
justement à chaque classe alors ce qui
nous a donné envie de traiter ce thème
de se poser cette question comment
enseigner l'histoire c'est un sondage
paru il y a quelques semaine et je
propose à Steve Jourdain de nous
rejoindre pour nous donner les détails
de de ce sondage rebonsoir Steve qui a
amené ce sondage certains a tiré la
sonnette d'alarme au sujet de la
génération Z les 16 24 ans oui c'est ni
votre génération ni la mienne c'est la
génération qui vient on parle des
enfants qui sont nés entre
1999 et 2007 l'institut OpinionWay a
réalisé en fin d'année dernière une
étude qui a été commandée par la
politologue Chloé Morin 904 86 personnes
de cette classe d'âge ont été interrogé
alors on leur a posé des questions de
culture générale il y avait pas de piège
particulier l'idé c'était de mieux
comprendre leur rapport à l'histoire et
à l'information avec des résultats
éloquents oui à peine plus d'un jeune
sur deux et capable de dire quand la
Révolution française a commencé 54 %
savent qu'elle a débuté en 1789 les
autres la font démarrer à une autre date
la chute du mur de Berlin 40 % descendés
on raison de dire qu'il est tombé en
1989 même difficulté pour le droit de
vote accordé aux femmes seulement 31 %
ont la bonne réponse 1944 enfin même
difficulté pour l'histoire dite
internationale l'État d'Israël qui a été
créé en 1948 seul 23 % des sondés ont
donné la bonne réponse c'est peut-être
encore plus inquiétant le le le rapport
à certains concept à certaines notions
oui on a demandé au sondé s'ils avaient
déjà entendu parler de certains thèmes
de certains termes de certaines idées
quasiment 40 % d'entre eux n'ont jamais
entendu parler de la rafle du valdif 32
% ne savent pas ce que signifi les mots
solution finale alors à l'inverse 85 %
ont entendu parler des chambres à gaz et
seulement il semble savoir ce que cela
signifie seulement 3 % n'en ont jamais
entendu parler mais tout de même 15 ce
des jeunes ont des doutes sur
l'existence de la Choa et puis toujours
au sujet de cette période de notre
histoire Thomas seulement 43 % des
jeunes affirment que l'État français a
eu a eu un rôle actif dans la
déportation des juifs vers les camps de
la mort et 41 % pensent qu'il l'a fait
uniquement sous la contrainte des nazis
bon quand on voit tous ces chiffres on
se dit c'est évidemment inquiétant il
faut le relativiser quand même ce
sondage oui comment en éant arrivé là
c'est la question qui nous vient bien
évidemment mais il faut peut-être
reformuler cette question car un tel
sondage n'avait jamais été réalisé
auparavant on ne sait pas comment ma
génération commment celle de nos parents
de celle celle de nos grands-parents
auraient répondu à ces mêmes questions
on ne sait même pas ce qu'ils pensent
actuellement de ces mêmes fait
historique difficile donc de dresser un
constat définitif sur ces jeunes c'est
pas rassurant certes mais si on élargit
un petit peu le spectre du sondage à
l'ensemble de la société et ben ce
serait peut-être encore plus inquiétant
merci beaucoup Steve Jourdain on
faudrait le faire ce sondage auprès de
tous les Français Christine votre avis
vous en pensez quoi de ce sondage alors
il faudrait voir déjà comment les
questions sont posées parce que et aussi
quel est le parcours scolaire des jeunes
qui ont été interrogés parce que si dans
le panel vous avez des jeunes qui ont eu
un parcours en lycée professionnel où on
ne cesse de réduire l'horaire
d'enseignement général où on a à peu
près une heure par semaine pour traiter
un programme qui est assez assez
ambitieux et très très peu de temps les
élèves ne risquent pas de retenir
grand-chose donc pour pouvoir avoir
une uneiss dur il faut du temps pour
travailler si vous demandez aux élèves
qu'est-ce que c'est que la solion finale
nous ce qu'on leur explique ça c'est du
vocabulaire
nazi si vous leur demandez le génocide
il y en aura beaucoup plus qui vont vous
donner la réponse le mot Choa c'est
quand même inquiétant le le le fait
qu'il soit mais la Choa c'est la choix
c'est enseigné c'est enseigné à je dis
pas que c'est pas enseigné c'est la
question c'est pourquoi ça n'infuse pas
alors ça dépend aussi de des mots qui
sont utilisés dans le cours ouais ça
c'est important le sens des mots au-delà
de cette question de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale sur la date de la Révolution
française ça vous frappe pas si si si
mais nous ce que nous constatons c'est
que nos élèves oublient ils oublient
régulièrement
et parce que ils passent d'un cours à
l'autre ils sont beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus sollicités par les pieds dans le
plat est-ce que c'est la façon
d'enseigner l'histoire qui est en cause
votre avis là-dessus je vous donne la
parole pour commencer alors la façon
d'enseigner l'histoire je ne sais pas
mais je veux quand même revenir sur la
deuxième guerre mondial parce que on est
dans un pays qui a eu un problème avec
la deuxème guerre mondiale et son
enseignement level la commémoration du
veld la reconnaissance de la
collaboration français c'est ja
1995 1995 et pendant très longtemps on a
plus ou moins nié tout ça donc ça a fait
des petits entre guillemets alors qu'il
y a un problème aujourd'hui de
mémorisation c'est effrayant mais on le
constate hein dans les plus petites
classes mais alors je repose la question
pardon he de de vous interrompre mais
puisque effectivement on entend c'est
peut-être totalement faux mais il y a
plus de chronologie dans l'U scolaire
alors bon alors votre avisus est-ce que
c'est la façon d'enseigner l'histoire
qui est en cause c'est totalement faux
les prog qu mê on quand même é
problématique prames sont
chronologiques il y a un minimum de base
chronologique mais on a effectivement en
parlant de l'histoire de France on a un
petit peu sorti certains pans de
l'histoire de France pour mettre des
pans d'histoire plus mondial entre
guillemets et peut-être que
effectivement puisque le le temps
d'enseignement est quand même assez
restreint il n en a pas assez en ce qui
concerne la chronologie
pure il a de la chronologie question
chologie pure sans contextualisation
sans travail sur les sources ça trouve
très vite ses limites ce qu'il faut
quand même faire comprendre à tous ceux
qui nous écoutent c'est que pour que les
élèves retiennent il faut passer
suffisamment de temps sur les notions
les concepts et les chapitres lorsqu'on
a des programmes qui sont des
mil000feuilles avec des élèves qui sont
fagocités par toutes sortes de
préoccupations on travaille moins bien
ensuite pour la chronologie l'histoire
de la France très honnêtement quand je
regarde les actuels programmes de
lycée le programme de Première commence
en 1789 fini avec les sorties de guerre
euh il il est vraiment centré sur
l'histoire de la France et de l'Europe
euh il y a pas de de de problème à
Mathie je vois Mathieu qui qui veut
intervenir j'ai fait des études
d'histoire et j'ai regarder les livres
d'histoires de mes enfants alors après
c'est c'est c'est ce n'est que mon point
de vue mais je trouve que l'approche a
changé c'est que l'approche les les
chapitres des livres d'histoire
d'Emmanuel que j'ai eu en ma possession
al de collège et de lycée ont une
approche documentaire et
contextualisante d'abord et après un
récapitulatif du cours généralement à en
fin de section et cette approche là moi
m'a surpris parce que c'est difficile de
rentrer je trouve à mes yeux dans une
enluminure ou dans peut-être que c'est
comme ça que ça marche mais je trouve
que la chronologie existe toujours c'est
vrai mais elle n'est pas mise au même
endroit je me demande si al après il
faut pas sacraliser les dates mais les
dates c'est aussi des moyens
mémotechniques et des repères c'est pas
on sait bien que ça ça bascule pas 1 je
sais pas si Benjam St veut rentrer dans
le débat mais peut-être je peux vous
poser ça fait quoi une trentaine
d'années que vous enseignez alors dans
le supérieur est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment pardon vous interrom est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment d'un d'un
niveau qui qui qui s'ffrite un petit peu
moi j'ai enseigné 35 ans dont 10 ans aux
langues orientales h devant des publics
extrêmement studieux et silencieux j'ai
enseigné l'histoire du Maghreb
contemporain et de la civilisation
musulmane il y avait à chaque fois 3 400
étudiants en amphithéâtre qui étaient
extrêmement studieux et qui voulaient
absolument sacaparer cette histoire
ouais a beaucoup beaucoup de profs de
lycées ou de collège qui qui rêveraient
d'unun par problème c'est combien y
a-t-il en France de professeurs des
université spécialiste du monde musulman
et du Magreb contemporain combien je
parle de l'université hein je parle pas
des professeurs de lycées et de collège
he ben pratiquement rien il y en a 5 ou
6 en France et tout c'estàd que l'école
orientaliste française donc le
sommet de la pyramide du point de vue de
la l'élaboration des récits historiques
pour ensuite transmettre la formation
des maîtres et bien c'est rarifier
c'estàdire que la grande école
orientaliste française est en panne
c'estàdire que le problème c'est qu'on
ne peut pas aborder les questions
d'esclavage et de colonisation en les
laissant uniquement sous l'angle entre
guillemets religieux ce sont des
phénomènes à caractère socio-historique
donc si nous n'avons pas suffisamment
d'enseignants et de professeurs formés
pour répondre aux sollicitations des
nouvelles populations issues des
immigrations post-coloniales je mets les
pieds dans le plat et bien les
professeurs ne peuvent pas répondre
savoir qui est feratabas qui est
messaliage qui est le sultan du B c'est
de l'histoire française c'est pas de
l'histoire mondialisée et cetera c'est
l'histoire française or sur cette
histoire française nous avons pris là du
retard dans la formation des élites des
professeurs il faut créer énormément de
postes de professeurs des universités
consacrés à l'histoire du Moyen-Orient
et du Maghreb ça faisait partie de vos
recommandations ou il y a 3 ans vous
l'avez remis ce rapport à Emmanuel
Macron il y a qu'est-ce qu'il est devenu
ce qu'il est devenu c'est qu'on a quand
même fait pas mal de trucson bon sur les
mir abdelcader à Amboise il y a eu une
ouverture plus grande des archives qui
ont été fait ce weekend s'est tenu à
Paris une réunion avec des historiens
algériens hmm où il a été décidé en
particulier de numériser plusieurs
millions d'archives en partage avec
l'Algérie donc ça c'est un phénomène
tout à fait nouveau de partager par la
numérisation des millions d'archives et
la restitution par la France des
archives ottomanes à l'Algérie ce sont
des ce sont des choses très très
importantes parce que euh le public qui
nous suit le public scolaire des lycées
des collèges bien sûr nous regarde sur
ces questions-là il nous observve sur
ces questions-là ce sont pas des
questions séparées
les TRX deette Commission fait an
maintenant on a fait réunions de cette
commission ça nintéresse personne je
parle dans les médias très lourd très
très important ça les intéresse pas les
restitutions d'archives les gestes
symboliques à effectuer la discussion
sur les restitution à caractère
symbolique c'est des questions très très
graves c'est qu'est-ce qu'il faut rentre
qu'est-ce qu'il faut garder qu'est-ce
qu'il faut conserver ce sont des
questions qui se posent non seulement à
nous comme professeur d'université ou
enseignant tout court mais au jeunes
public scolarisé qui est très attentif à
ça parce que tout à l'heure vous posiez
la question de l'enseignement du comment
les musées la question des musées en
histoire la question des musées
d'histoire de la colonisation et de la
décolonisation est posée et d'ailleurs
le président de la républ a posé cette
question c'est pas encore public mais il
pose cette question de de de savoir s'il
faut ou non un musé d'histoire de la
commun ça veut dire que on n pas
affronté cette histoire ça revient un
peu ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
sur le pard interom n pas affronté cette
histoireirac a posé la question du Musée
d'histoire de l'immigration oui et il
fallait affronter cette questionl il l'a
affronté parce qu'il y a eu
effectivement 95 mais il y a eu le musée
d'histoire d'immigration que j'ai
présidé pendant 6 ans donc par
conséquent il faut aussi trouver les
lieux de transmission de cette histoire
à la fois par la formation des maîtres
et par des lieux qui sont directement en
prise avec les sollicitations d'un
public scolaire de plus en plus nombreux
sur les questions touchant à la question
coloniale et à la question de
l'esclavage oui mais Benjamin stor il a
été chargé d'une mission pour essayer de
réconcilier apaiser des mémoires
peut-être qu'au sujet de la colonisation
en général le temps n'est pas encore
venu de l'apaisement et j'espère qu'il
viendra au plus vite mais vis-à-vis de
la deuxème guerre mondiale et et du
veldive on a eu une période de déc très
longue et et et en histoire on sait bien
que que le poids du temps est clé pour
permettre des fois de mieux comprendre
de mieux accepter certaines
problématiques certaines si décennies on
va dire ça ne suffit pas c'est encore
trop trop trop vif pour certain je pense
que pour certaines populations qui
vivent en France aujourd'hui mais qui
sont originaires par leurs
grands-parents arrière grands-parents
effectivement du Maghreb peut-être que
c'est difficile d'accepter d'entendre
certaines choses peut-être avec des des
enfants d'aujourd'hui des collégiens ou
des lycéens qui ont évidemment pas connu
la décolonisation ou et la colonisation
et qui malgré tout l'utilise comme une
référence dans leur façon de de de de
percevoir certains certains cours que
vous leur donnez ça dépend quand on
travaille avec eux sur le la place de
leurs histoires familiale dans la entre
guillemets grande
histoire il y en a qui se sonent plus
concernés et je me rappelle très bien
d'un une discussion là sur la d'Algérie
donc on parle d'arquy et tout de suite
il y a qui fuse ouais l' c'est des
traîtres qu'est-ce que ça veut dire le
la réponse est très très courte et à
chaque fois que potentiellement j'ai ce
problème là moi j'ai l'habitude de
travailler avec Fatima B n en coup elle
vient pass dans est dans ma classe elle
fait un atelier de 2hur elle leur
explique et après ils ont un une vision
des des choses qui est totalement
différente donc pour revenir justement
au au témoignage dont dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure un témoin de l'histoire
qui peut être aussi une victime les deux
il remplace pas le cours d'histoire il
va s'insérer à l'intérieur qu'il y a un
travail en amont il y a le témoignage de
la personne donc en l'occurrence la cité
l Lili liel oou Ginette colinka il va
être les vie et ensuite il y a du
travail en aval c'està-dire que c'est
ça fait partie de de toute la démarche
qu'on va mener avec les élèves et ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur la la
bande dessiné et la lecture c'est c'est
fondamental parce que les élèves
continuent de lire oui quand on leur
apporte des livres quand on leur donne
des conseils de lecture ils partent avec
il le lisent et après ils viennent en
parler à à leurs camarades la même chose
pour les pour les musées c'est c'est une
accroche très importante et le le film
de fiction moi je me souviens d'avoir
travaillé à plusieurs reprises avec le
film de Marceline Loridan la petite
prairie au boulot ça permet de faire
comprendre qu'est-ce que c'est que la
mémoire par rapport à l'histoire euh
l'oubli les traumatismes et honnêtement
euh un film bien utilisé c'est c'est un
bon support alors on va parler
maintenant ouvrir un chapitre sur la
façon dont dont les les politiques
s'approprie euh se dispute ou
instrumentalise l'histoire avant de vous
donner la parole Mathieu sur sur ce
thème on écoute un témoignage un
professeur d'histoire euh qui est prof
en classe prépa euh et il faisait partie
des signes ataire d'une tribune qui
dénonçait très clairement des
manipulations du passé ce sont les
termes de de cette tribune signé Erric
Zemour il nous a semblé que c'était
important de faire entendre
collectivement une parole d'historien
pas pour jouer au prof sévère avec le
stylo rouge pour dire attention erreur
mais pour dire attention en tant que
citoyen et en tant que professionnel de
l'histoire on tient à pointer un certain
nombre de choses qui relèvent de la
manipulation du passé qui fausse le
débat démocratique c'est important parce
qu'en fait il a beaucoup écrit sur
l'histoire il parle beaucoup d'histoire
dans ses interventions médiatiques et du
coup il y a aussi bien des énormités sur
le moyen-âge que sur la période moderne
que sur la Révolution française dont il
laisse entendre qu'elle serait un
complot mené par des Jacobins en passant
complètement à côté de la dynamique
révolutionnaire sur le 19e siècle
l'affaire drefus en laissant croire que
drefus serait peut-être pas innocent la
Première Guerre mondiale la deuxième
guerre mondiale évidemment la
colonisation Mathieu la la politique
sens large instrumentalise l'histoire
oui et depuis toujours depuis
l'Antiquité sur le forum déjà on s'en
servait pour célébrer la grandeur ou la
décadence de Rome à la fin du 19e on le
sait à l'heure de l'instruction
obligatoire l'histoire fut même utilisée
pour composer ce fameux récit national
et fédérer de bons petits citoyens
français tu dois aimer la France parce
que la nature la faête belle et parce
que l'histoire laa faête grande
pouvait-on lire sur les manuels
scolaires d'Ernest lavis C alors c'était
une conception très chronologique là
pour le coup de l'histoire héroïsant les
grandes figures qui a été évidemment
très fermement CR critiqué par les
historiens dès l'apparition de l'école
des anales mais ça n'a pas empêché cette
vision utilitariste du du du roman
national de perdurer dans l'imaginaire
politique en 2016 François Fillon en
pleine primaire de droite se désole
ainsi que les jeunes Français ignorent
despend de leur histoire et invite déjà
à réécrire les programmes avec ouvr les
guillemets l'idée de les concevoir comme
un récit national une histoire faite
d'hommes et de femmes de symboles de
lieux de monuments d'événements qui
trouvent un sens et une signification
dans l'édification progressive de la
civilisation singulière de la France une
histoire fait d'événement à condition de
se mettre d'accord sur les événements
oui on l'a vu dans l'extrait c'est loin
d'être évident encore plus depuis
l'irruption d'une vérité alternative
dans les discours qui n'hésite pas à
remettre en cause des faits historiques
alors là les exemples étaient avec Éric
Zemour on l'a rappelé qui jetait la
suspicion sur l'innocence de drefus où
affirmait que Pétin avait sauvé des
Juifs en mettant les historiens au défi
de venir lui apporter un démentil alors
des propos qui lui ont valu des
poursuites sur le terrain judiciaire
dans un tout autre registre on a aussi
les insoumis qui au le cor parfois
certains événements révolutionnaires
souvenez-vous la marche à versaill des
femmeschon disait il n'y a pas eu une
tête coupée B pas de peau il y en avait
deux c'était les gardes du corps de de
marieantonet oua l' histoire qui sert
aussi d'argument politique oui au fond
si je résume moi je trouve il y a trois
choses qui me frappent dans la façon
dont les politiques utilisent l'histoire
d'abord une forme de mésusage l'histoire
est devenue un Fourtout rhétorique mais
personne ne l'utilise à bontion on le
rappelait plutôt que d'éclairer les
choix du présent en remettant perspec
h ser essentiellement je trouve soit de
refuge soit deoussoir en gros la droite
s'en sert de refuge en la considérance
sous langue de la nostalgie vous savez
ce fameux bon vieux temps que personne
n'est jamais capable de dater d'ailleurs
le temps où tout allait mieux c'était
mieux avant et puis la gauche elle en
use et en abuse parfois sous l'angle des
or sombres des or sinistres de
l'histoire dès qu'une mesure lui déplaît
ça c'est le premier mes usages la
deuxième chose qui me frappe je trouve
c'est la dimension morale que les PO
tique voudrait faire jouer à l'histoire
toutes les polémiques autour de la
notion de repentance par exemple et qui
nous enferme dans une forme de choix
binaire alors que l'histoire c'est
regarder son passé en face et sous
toutes ses facettes c'est pas en avoir
honte ni en être fier c'est pas ça
l'histoire et puis la TR dimension
morale voilà et la troisième chose enfin
qui explique peut-être un peu les deux
premières je trouve c'est le mélange des
genres entretenu par la politique entre
l'histoire on en parlait la mémoire et
même d'une certaine façon le patrimoine
historique de quoi une nation doit elle
se souvenir que doit-elle célébrer c'est
pas forcément la même chose que ce
qu'elle doit enseigner Olivier PAC la
droite est-ce qu'elle est forcément
nostalgique quand elle s'approprie
l'histoire je ne sais pas mais ce que je
veux vous dire parce que j'ai j'ai j'ai
bien aimé ce qu'a dit Matthieu
croissando c'est que les noces entre
l'histoire et la politique peuvent être
parfois dangereuses elles peuvent être
merveilleuses je vais vous donner un
exemple
allez-y la poignée de main colle
mitteran septembre 84 devant le uer de
douumont oui c'était de la mémoire
politique c'était beau c'était beau vous
avez parlé de l'utilisation par les
politiques de l'histoire le le premier
livre de propagande de l'histoire
politique c'est la guerre des Gaules de
César mais bien sûr et depuis tout temps
en fait les politiques ont utilisé
l'histoire et nous dans notre France je
vais vous donner un seul exemple c'est
le choix de notre fête nationale 14 de
juillet 1790 et pas 89 il y a eu des
débats il y a eu des débats à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat pour savoir si
c'était le 5 mai le 20 le 20 juin le 21
septembre on a beaucoup débattu et on a
choisi une date très symbolique qui
alliait 89 et 90 alors que la vraie date
c'était 90 dans l'esprit du
législateur à chaque fois que le
politique utilise l'histoire il ne fait
pas de la manipulation dans nos
démocraties mais il y a un
incontestablement un un une volonté
d'utiliser parfois pas de façon négative
mais pour essayer de fonder
réunir la nation entre guillemets et on
en a besoin et l'outi historique est une
matière précieuse qui peut être
détournée mais il y a difficilement
matière plus précieuse que l'histoire
pour ressouder une nation en fait
Benjamin St sur le finalement ce que
Mathie nous disait sur la notion
repentance c'est au cœur de de de l'un
des aspects importants des travaux que
vous avez menés sur la colonisation et
et la guerre d'Algérie non
mais la repentance à chaque fois qu'onut
parler
colon parce que c'est justement le
billet politique qu'on peutut prendre
repentance personne je veux dire c'est
un argument politique polémique le crime
contre l'humanité qu'avait utilisé
président Macron voilà part président de
la République mais la question de la 20
an c'est un argument polémique c'est un
argument politique c'est pas un argument
qui consiste à aller au fond de ce qui
est l'histoire coloniale c'est dès qu'on
veut dire il faut agrandir l'histoire de
France et rentrer dans une histoire qui
ne reste pas à la périphérie
c'est-à-dire l'histoire de la
colonisation française la plus grande
France c'est comme ça qu'on appelit la
France avant alors dès qu'on dit ça on
dit H repentance on peut pas et cetera
attention
binaire avir
hte c'est qu'on ne peut pas rentrer dans
cette histoire de manière
c'est ça la grande question de manière
sereine de manière distanciée et
critique aussi et donc à partir de là on
sort comme ça des mots tabou du type
repentance du type flagélation du type
je sais pas quoi et cetera or il faut
faire tout simplement de l'histoire et
pas de l'histoire communautarisé mais de
l'histoire tout court c'estàd qu'on
raconte et qu'on élargisse le récit
historique et ça demande du temps c'est
vrai ça demande beaucoup d'efforts
beaucoup d'écriture d'aller aux archives
connaître les sources c'est du temps du
temps passé c'est c'est du
et je reviens à notre titre et ces
pressions au pluriel dont on parle
chrisinee Guimet comment on est arrivé à
ce que les professeurs d'histoire gé
puissent devenir des cibles parce que
c'est la réalité dramatique de ces C
dernières annes ça ça nous inquiète
parce que c'est pas notre rôle d'être
des cibles nous on est là
pour apprendre l'histoire à nos élèves
leur ouvrir l'esprit leur donner des
clés pour comprendre un monde qui est de
plus en plus
complexe le les aider aussi à analyser
pourquoi ce qu'une génération apprenait
en classe est différent de ce que la
génération suivante
apprend moi mon programme de terminale
s'est arrêtait en 1945 donc j'ai appris
la Gard d'Algérie en classe réparatoire
euh au collège et au lycée le rafle du
veldif c'était pas écrit dans les
manuels donc je l'ai je l'ai appris en
faisant des recherches toute seule donc
il faut être lucide parce que plutôt
rependance plutôt une lucidité par
rapport à l'histoire éviter de confondre
le récit et le roman parce que en
histoire on fait automatiquement un
récit on raconte ce qui se passe et je
connais peu de professeurs qui ne vont
pas contextualiser le chapitre en
dessinant une frise chronologique pour
bien placer les éléments clés pour
qu'après on puisse entrer dans le cours
les documents ça sert à mettre les
élèves en situation un petit peu de de
chercheurs pour qu'il travaillent sur
les archives mais c'est par exemple
quand on parle de laïcité aujourd'hui
plus personne montre les des carature de
maahomé c'est plus possible il y a des
collègues qui le qui le font bien sûr et
honnêtement les caricatures de de la
charnière fin 19e début 20e sont
incomparativement plus violentes donc
pour travailler
suroui pour travailler sur la caricature
il faut faire un travail sur le temps
long pour montrer les les différents
types de de dessin et l'idée oui mais il
faut impérativement montrer une
caricature tel jour en cours c'est une
aberration pédagogique parce que un un
dessin de presse une caricature ça se
contextualise c'est le la manière dont
un dessinateur va
euh percevoir un événement à un moment
donné si je peux me permettre le
professeur d'Histoire est certainement
plus visé que d'autres enseignants euh
même si euh un professeur de littérature
de SVT ou autre peut être aussi cri et
et par différents groupes de pression
hein évidemment on a mis pression a mis
pressionriel c'est une matière qui est
potique on peut citer les parents
vigilants proche d'éc Zemour on peut
citer des des parents
catholiques intégristes qui vont mettre
la pression à un cours de SVT et cetera
enfin la liste peut être malheureusement
longue mais je pense que si le
professeur d'Histoire est plus
d'histoiregéographie hein dans notre
République et plus ciblé que d'autres
c'est parce que il contribue plus que
les autres enseignants à former le
citoyen or ceux qui s'attaquent entre
guillemets au professeur d'histoire
géographie s'attaque à notre
civilisation à notre République à notre
volonté de démocratie de liberté
d'expression d'égalité hommes-femme et
c'est parce que dans les cours
d'histoire on insiste sur cet aspect
effectivement on sème des graines de
citoyens en fait les professeurs
d'histoire ils essayent de le faire avec
beaucoup d'objectivité mais ils siment
des graines de citoyenneté et c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont beaucoup plus que
d'autres des
cibles il nous reste une minute donc
quand on entend des politiques critiquer
en permanence la manière dont on
enseigne c'est pas comme ça qu'on nous
aide nous on n pas besoin qu'on nous
dise comment faire notre
travail d'accord faire confiance bien
sûr le message est clair donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que à chaque
nouveau
mininenter oui ah mais bien sûr à chaque
nouveau ministre de quoi une réforme des
manuels qui changent enfin c'est ça ce
que vous ce que ce que vousz c'est une
forme d'inabilité de bougeotte qui est
un petit peu pénible que les program
mais parfois on a aussi l'impression
alors c'est un autre débat que les
syndicats de prof surtout pas bouger
quoi vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est aussi depu depuis que j'enseigne
depuis que j'enseigne il y a il y a des
réformes en permanence donc on peut pas
dire que l'éducation nationale c'est
quelque chose d'immobile c'est sûr que
c'est un pquebo qui est plus difficile à
faire tourner qu'un petit
bateau mais pour enseigner l'histoire on
a besoin de temps d'un horaire suffisant
de programmes qui soi réaliste pour
qu'on puisse les travailler correctement
avec nos élèves pour qu'ils aient une
connaissance durable et on n pas
vraiment besoin et même pas du tout que
notre métier soit instrumentalisé
politiquement on termine là-dessus merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat qui était passionnant je vais
rappeler évidemment Benjamin Stora le
titre de votre livre l'arrivée de
Constantine à Paris qui est publiée aux
éditions Talandier voilà c'est la fin de
ce sens public merci à toutes et à tous
de votre fidélité on se retrouve demain
à 18h et 22h ce sera Mathieu croissandau
à la présentation je vous laisse les les
manettes Mathieu amusez-vous bien demain
bonne émission et puis Noez que l'invité
politique de la ura face à elle à 8h
Florence sportell la vice-présidente du
parti les républicains belle
soirée